[Music]
[Applause]
he plays coach beard on Ted lasso I
don't know if Brandon wants to join us
now but Brandon Hunt joining us on the
program uh come on in stay a while uh
good to talk to you how are you I mean
gosh do I got to start my day with Taco
filthy crudite yeah how many days well
that's a normal day for you
so uh take me back to when it's this all
started
uh sure I mean first of all uh Brendan
hunt uh six foot nothing 195. all right
and I uh yeah we did these commercials
for uh NBC Sports
um because they got the coverage of the
Premier League back in 2013.
um the offer was to fly me and and Jason
acres and Joe Kelly to London for three
whole days and we were like three days
in London
that's the job of a lifetime
um so we happily took it and uh now
we're uh three years into a TV show this
crazy dumb thing but when the promos
were done when did the the idea of we
could make this a show
we we did the promos uh two years in a
row because the the first one went well
enough that like that ad company won
like you know whatever kind of awards
they went for for ads and um and after
the second one me and Joe and Jason I
mean Jason particularly was like hey
guys this thing is fun right there's
something more to this than than some of
its parts let's figure out something
more to do with it we didn't know if it
was a movie or more commercials or a TV
show but we started thinking about a TV
show and thinking about in the in the
model of the UK office of uh six
episodes six episodes and a special you
know sort of three chunks
um we wrote up a pilot we we put
together a structure and um and then
nothing happened for about five years uh
Jason and Joe's careers were going very
well I was rotting on a block
very much considering a career return to
dinner theater uh and then at the last
minute
um a couple years ago Jason was like oh
having lunch with Bill Lawrence tomorrow
we'll see what happens and this happened
uh is it a benefit an advantage to no
more soccer or less soccer
um in in my shoes it's a benefit
um because it turns out even though we
have some English people on the writing
staff I'm like the soccer guy
um and every once in a while I just get
turned into like okay Brandon what would
happen here and I tell them what would
really happen for a given situation and
then we generally ignore that
um but it's it's good to know what's
supposed to happen before we break the
rule of uh of what we decide to actually
do because you're sort of a savant but I
don't know if people realize you're a
soccer Savant during the show is that
fair with your character
um yeah I mean I think it's I think it's
kind of kind of at least comparatively
you know certainly compared to most of
the rest of America
um because I didn't get into soccer
until I was in my mid-20s and when I uh
had this job in Amsterdam doing comedy
out there
and then I discovered that soccer didn't
suck
um and I became a sponge and tried to
just you know soak up every every bit of
history and trivia and and factualities
that I possibly could
um and uh and it hasn't gone away since
I've since I've moved to the states I'm
still now full on soccer nut the
reaction in the United States compared
to the reaction in England
how big of a discrepancy disparity
between the two when it first started
um well it just when I first started
yeah no one in England knew who we were
uh at all uh and we could walk freely
among them
um and then shooting the second season
was was coveted mostly so we could still
kind of walk around but now year three
you know I decided for year three I was
going to live in Richmond I could I'm
sure I could do so quite anonymously the
UK isn't watching this show yet
um and I wanted the pub from the show to
be my local
um well by year three the UK has caught
up to Ted lasso and I can no longer go
to that Pub uh it's like
um if if tourists go to Boston and they
go to the Cheers bar and suddenly Cliff
is there
um
and uh so you actually would go to the
bar that you go to a local pub
Richmond's awesome and uh Richmond green
you know that little that little Park
basically where the uh the pub is in
real life in the show is hypnotically
quaint I I would I would spend weeks at
a time there if I possibly could except
now I I absolutely can't the timing with
covid
uh it felt like you know we needed feel
good every a lot of these shows are let
me pick out the guy that is the least
detestable and everybody's detestable
like succession you know you watch and
you go well you don't like any of them
but you do love the show it was
different with uh with Ted lasso but I
don't know what role kovid played or the
pandemic and we're at home and needing
feel-good stories played and the success
yeah we're not quite sure either I mean
um and obviously you know we we sure
would have preferred that people were
watching it
um you know of their own volition and
you know despite having plenty of
options of how they could do their night
now here we were with a captive audience
and uh if you're gonna have a captive
audience at least at least make them
feel a little better
um but certainly the show was written
before covid and edited during covet and
then it finally came out yeah like at a
real Cove at High Point about six months
into it I guess and
whether that was a a
you know a multiplier or not from then
on the reaction that we were getting
from people even before a lot of people
were watching the show was immediately
intense and really like like a elevated
kind of connection for a show that had
only just come out and it's been pretty
breathtaking to be to be part of we're
talking to Brendan hunt the actor writer
producer he's coach beard on Ted lasso
season three arrived final season
apparently on uh Apple TV plus uh
that'll be Wednesday March 15th final
final season
um we just don't know for sure right now
um you know again we've always saw this
as like a three sweep movement and here
we are
um with the uh with the conductor waving
that baton uh with a sense of finality
and we're we're definitely ending this
story we started out to tell but that
doesn't necessarily mean it's the it's
the end end it does mean we're gonna
we're gonna finish this up and we're
gonna take a little break
um because we're very tired of each
other's adorable uh hairy faces and uh
and after about a year and a half or so
we'll come back together and see what's
up give me the episode where you go I
can't believe we're doing this
[Music]
um
uh I guess season the first episode of
season two where we really felt it was
important to start things off by killing
a dog
um because we had become by then you
know that the feel-good show the show
that's like a hug
um I don't know we're kind of a sitcom
guys
um just just remind everybody what's up
here we're just gonna kill a dog right
away you know break break the first rule
of sitcoms and uh everybody can just sit
a little further away from their
television for a little bit and we'll
get you back we'll get you back but
whose idea was it to kill the dog
reading Twitter he was crying and all
the reactions like oh my God this show
means so much to people we have to kill
a dog
right away
I wonder if you had a spin-off of one of
one or two of the characters coming to
the United States
I mean there are there have been some
pitches there are there are some things
on the table
um and uh and I'm not at Liberty to say
but to your you're on the right track
Dan oh okay all right it's gonna happen
but you're on the right track
when's the last time you got mad at
Jason
I mean uh bless Jason's heart like he's
built to suffer uh uh a million micro
mads
um you know because he just he's on his
own time
um he will answer emails uh and texts at
his own at his own pace
um which is very understandable the
man's got the weight of the world on his
shoulders and all that but like uh oh
Jason please I just gotta let this guy
know if if I need three tickets or four
please just just tell me just tell me
um so I'd say uh 10 times a day really
final answer
who would uh who do you model your
acting career after
well I mean
um I mean we you know whenever you're
trying to set your life up you
definitely want to like try to find that
person who no one knew about until they
were 48 years old
I mean Lee Jones was like that though
Brendan
no that's it we did it tell me tell me
Tommy Lee Jones I could have been a vice
president for a roommate this all would
have happened just a little bit faster
but you know okay but you're playing a
coach do you Channel any coaches you
know you're obviously you grew up in
Chicago so you're a sports fan do you
kind of say okay this is the coach or
coaches I'm gonna
kind of form my personality with
um I am a rather poor athlete Dan and I
just have not had many coaches in my
life I've had a lot of acting teachers
and I've had a lot of cool bosses and um
um but you've watched Sports you know
Phil Jackson or it might be you know a
football coach it could be Bill Parcells
or Bill Belichick Mike Ditka it's
anything it's Tex winter
um because
it's a guy who is perfectly happy being
on the sidelines
um you got to explain text to people who
aren't you know familiar with Tex winner
happily
um uh folks might know uh Phil Jackson
Who uh of course his glittering career
got really going when he was the coach
of Michael Jordan at the Bulls and they
won the six titles and um but his
offense was a triangle offense which was
uh accredited uh to his assistant coach
Tex winter who literally written the
book on the subject decades earlier and
tex winter was just happily an old man
with gray hair and a real nice suit that
got nicer every year uh sitting a few
seats down from Phil he had no
um you know Julius Caesar aspirations or
Brutus aspirations of taking any other
seed he was perfectly happy where he was
and he knew his place and he'd be there
for Phil no matter what
um and and that's that's really where
what beard is you know he's the opposite
of like say you know Charlie Weiss who's
like wow we're a really good team
I should probably be a head coach now
oh
not being Charlie wise as much as I am
about trying to be anyone else but text
winter yeah I'll stick with that are you
in the bracket celebrity bracket
challenge with us
March Madness knowledge but I but you
know I I've been losing brackets for
decades Dan I'd happily do it here too
all right fritzy did you reach out to
Brendan we did sounds like uh we're
gonna work that out and he'll be a part
of it okay can you teach timing
comedic timing
I think you can but you have to start
young and you have to really drill it
like I think I learned timing from uh
you know neglectful parents who didn't
necessarily know for sure that I was
going to school even as far back as
first grade and so I stayed home and
watched every day watched Bugs Bunny and
Tom and Jerry and Woody Woodpecker and
uh yes those were violent you're not
allowed to watch them anymore but my God
the the clinic in in timing was
invaluable and so I don't know I don't
know if you can like you know just show
up to some uh you know uh random Master
Class A video and get it but um but Bugs
Bunny will set you straight for sure
what was it uh the advice Jerry Seinfeld
gave us be uh loud and Fast on a sitcom
that uh that has been the rule for for
many many a sitcom for the last several
years and that's because it's been the
rule it's kind of been maxed out by like
essentially the greatest sitcoms of all
time
so we very consciously have sort of
broken that rule uh from the beginning
we go a little quieter and a little
slower and we lure them in uh with a
like a hypnotizing them and no dog dies
in season three
I can't speak to that okay all right
okay all right does anybody die in
season three oh everybody dies
El is this like The Sopranos of soccer
like it everybody dies at the end
yeah it fades to Black in the 89th
minute I like it I like it uh hey great
to meet you congrats on being an
overnight success after 49 years but uh
we look forward to season three that
drops as we like to say Wednesday March
15th thank you Brendan thank you Dan
this is a thrill man appreciate it
that's uh Brendan hunt actor writer
producer all-around good guy coach beard
on Ted lasso